you need to have flags or circuit
breakers if you want to call them that
like there needs to be a behavioral
circuit breaker and for him what it was
was
if you're having fun in the midst of a
conversation
or in the midst of a debate um you're
probably
you probably need to step away welcome
to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
this episode is going to be all about
the psychology of leadership
i welcome christopher cultus with me
vice president of product innovation and
a senior leadership consultant at
leadership worth following llc
he personifies the scientist
practitioner model in the fast-growing
field of industrial organizational
psychology
he has coached hundreds of leaders and
dozens of teams on how to leverage
enhanced self-awareness for optimal
leadership impact
his book with leadership worth following
driven not drained
discover your path to career happiness
effectiveness and influence
is a candid engaging and comprehensive
look at both the science and practical
application behind human behavior
chris cultist welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
are you in
texas right now i am yeah thanks for
having me i'm in the dfw area
amazing amazing thank you for joining i
love that i get to talk to people all
over the us and all over the world and
this episode like i mentioned right
before we started is is special to me
because
if you know most episodes i get to dive
into a very specific
niche and domain and problem now i get
to talk a little bit more broadly also
about something that i'm experiencing
myself and a lot of my
friends are as well you know i'm
watching
friends and you know in my university
you know
this idea of driven and drained um
and this idea of motivation and purpose
and
the tech ecosystem today and i'm really
excited to talk to you now
with a phd from the university of
central florida in industrial and
organizational psychology
but chris before we even get all into
all that i really want to know what
brought you to be so curious about the
psychology of organizations
and leaders well i've always been
curious just about kind of why people do
what they do
um and i i got into psychology because
of that just generally and i think most
people get into psychology
thinking they'll end up being a
counselor therapist or something like
that
as i explored that so i kind of started
pursuing that
and realized that that was not going to
be a good fit for me just kind of from a
personality standpoint
i don't think i would be able to kind of
turn it off
and and so that would have led me to
burn out so
i pivoted because i wanted to help
organizations
uh be more effective i mean work is a
huge part of our lives
and so you know if i can um play my
small part
in making work life better and and
honestly at some point i'd love to do
this kind of stuff with
with non-profits and help non-profits be
more effective
um so yeah just kind of doing my small
part to
make the world a better place by helping
leaders and organizations be better
so my issue with this conversation of
draining and motivation is that a lot of
times people look at
you know young entrepreneurs that are
working so hard and and
you know what they they keep turning us
off and they say stop don't do so much
take a break
and and you know it's very contradicting
to what you know what we feel and so
it doesn't really help and so i'm
curious to hear now from more of a
scientific
and research perspective what is this
you know what's happening in 2021
and and what are what have you been
observing you know especially in this
idea of
driven and drained yeah so i mean
2020 was crazy and 2021 is um
different but similar in a lot of ways
right we're still
we're still kind of transitioning out of
out of that hopefully
um but you know i think that as you as
you think about entrepreneurs
and you think about the like the like
the passion that draws you
into being an entrepreneur of course
that's going to
lead you into working a ton
and and in outside looking in
it makes a lot of sense that people are
going to tell
entrepreneurs to kind of slow down
um maybe not work so hard and i think
that
um there is there's some wisdom in that
but i think where i would
uh where i would qualify that
advice or that statement is not to say
work less but work more intentionally
and and really that's what a lot of my
work is about is giving people
uh the self-awareness to realize
because it's so easy when you get sucked
into something that you're passionate
about
uh to to kind of fall into tunnel vision
of the our own traps that our own
personality can
draw us into and and
the beauty of self-awareness and
intentionality is
you can still do everything that you're
passionate about you can still do what
you love
but taking the time to
step away zoom out for a minute and
realize
if i keep doing it like this
then i can get myself into some big
trouble
so i mean i'm i'm happy to share uh
share thoughts or share kind of
anecdotes on that but i'll pause there
just for your reactions on that
no no no please i'm i'm i'm excited to
hear them yes
oh yeah yeah um so like
a an example of that then uh
i was working with a a younger leader
who
first time kind of building his team
managing people
and um and so one of his his kind of mo
how what made him successful was he was
just super willing to be super helpful
and and he enjoyed it he enjoyed being
kind of like the thought leader
enjoyed being the person that you know
you could go to
and be helpful but what he found
was that over time people were coming to
him
with less and less relevant things
things that were outside of his
wheelhouse uh
but he couldn't stop himself uh
from saying yes uh and and he had this
kind of compulsion
to to be helpful he felt like it was
wrong to say no
and so he was pursuing this kind of
style
of i want to be helpful and it ended up
being really problematic because he
spread himself so thin
he was kind of going off vector in terms
of his career path
um and so that's just that's that's
maybe not a super entrepreneurial
example but it isn't it like it kind of
gives you a hint of
if you're not doing something if you're
doing things
thoughtlessly if you're pursuing your
career
thoughtlessly then you're apt
to get sucked into some of the unhelpful
aspects
of whatever your personality might be
right and so you know you take a person
like this and i think it's
you know you can just extrapolate on
that example to a bunch of other
behaviors that that people may have
yeah and and so you know what what do
you do then
what are some things that a person in
that situation could do
because you know once you get into a
spiral and you once you get into a bad
habit
you know whether it's working hard or
some other you know abuse of some other
behavior
you know i i definitely don't know how
to deal with that
uh yeah so there's a couple of things i
i
with this specific example uh what i
found that was super helpful with
with this guy was um was calibrating his
expectations
um and this is where uh like scientific
assessments can be really helpful um but
you don't necessarily have to
to go that far but basically in
in the assessment that our our firm uses
the drive
uh he scored a 97th percentile on
this driver called service so he was
driven to be helpful
service was hugely important to him and
what i challenged him on was
uh you're expect you are the outlier
your expectations and you're holding
yourself to an excessively high standard
you will still be a more helpful than
most person
even if you challenge yourself to say no
more
so that's kind of one technique uh the
other technique and then i'll pause and
and hear your thoughts but
uh i was working with another guy who um
who he loves to get into debates
he just loves to you know once you get
into it and
and maybe you're like that i don't know
but uh you know if it's a fun topic you
kind of go back and forth
uh for him what feels like a fun
conversation
to the average joe or jane is probably
like
wow you're coming on way too strong way
too intense
and that's part of his personality
that's part of his motivators
um and and so what i i
challenged him on and and maybe this is
something that you can kind of take away
is um you need to have
flags or circuit breakers if you want to
call them that
like there needs to be a behavioral
circuit breaker and for him what it was
was
if you're having fun in the midst of a
conversation
or in the midst of a debate you're
probably
you probably need to step away because
if you're having fun
that means the more statistically
speaking
the other person probably isn't
wow and so what you actually you know
describing here this idea of you know
the circuit breakers is
sort of like these personalized flags
that
give you this alert that even though
your your mind is telling you
one thing or your intuition is telling
you one thing you're basing off of you
know sort of science or statistics
that is actually something else and and
you've identified these different
circuit breakers that allow you to then
just modify the environment around you
this ties back a lot for me to the
research
i got to do with with professor donna
really on you know on irrationality
and and you know why we do what we do
when it comes to irrational
thinking and then you know his thesis
you know considering all the research
he's done really comes down to
the point of you know we don't we can't
really control our own irrationality but
we can very much control our environment
and so if i know that i'm not going to
be able to resist the chocolate cake
well then i shouldn't bring a chocolate
cake into the house
in the first place because i don't want
to be put in that situation right
exactly yeah no i think that's a great
example
now talk to me a little bit about you
know career happiness sustained career
happiness because until now
we're talking about behaviors we're
talking about you know things that may
make us
more or less happy in the day-to-day
maybe leading to burnout which is
obviously a big problem
can lead to other side effects but when
we're talking about
sustainable career and especially in the
world of leadership
you know what what is sort of the
science or or the interesting
ideas that are being put forth in those
in those domains
yeah so i would say there's um
there's probably two or three things to
touch on there
um one is and it one is it goes back to
what we were just talking about actually
is that self-awareness um because
i i think what happens uh especially
early in careers
is uh happiness is really complex
uh in in the assessment that i've i've
kind of mentioned
in our book driven not drain their their
we found that there are 28 things
that uh that motivate or drive behavior
drive happiness
and i mean that's a lot of things to
kind of balance at the same time
right and and when people talk about
chasing your happiness
uh or chasing your passion uh that often
leads to kind of like a tunnel vision or
a very
narrow or myopic way of pursuing your
career
so i'm driven by creativity
and so let me go pursue a
creative job but i didn't
i i but i didn't take into consideration
the fact that i'm
uh drained by deliberation and
bureaucracy
and collaboration and those kinds of
things and so
i end up taking a job that makes me
happy in one
area of who i am but really just sucks
the life out of me in another area
right right and so you know especially
for young
you know entrepreneurs and today you
know decision making
especially in the tech ecosystem becomes
earlier and earlier
and oftentimes you're you're dealt with
life decisions
and that you know previously people just
didn't have the privilege to be
you know to be to be able to handle and
so you know what are ways
that we can be intentional and
thoughtful as we go about making those
those decisions properly yeah so i think
there's two things
one is uh is is actually developing the
self-awareness beforehand
uh before you get into the situation
that way
you're able to be thoughtful and um and
kind of make a decision that is aligned
with who you are
um but i think the other thing is is
really getting a sense
of uh or is designing or developing
more realistic expectations and
and that's a big thing that i see in
early career professionals
is early career professionals tend to
have
uh are really driven by
purpose they're really driven by this
like i i want to change the world
but paradoxically they're also uh they
often tend to be drained
by some of the things that might
actually help them
change the world and so you have this
expectation that things are going to be
amazing
um but you overlook the fact that
there's a lot of a lot of hard work and
a lot of grind work and
and things like that and so i would i
would encourage
early career professionals and
entrepreneurs to
um to kind of temper expectations
um going into into any role
so leadership worth following what what
is that what is
you know and i'm asking that also in the
context
of you know what are ways for leaders in
today's world to become better leaders
aside from just you know going through
experiences and trying to
you know debrief and and get it better
by themselves
what is leadership worth following and
you know what is the greater
trend that we have today in terms of
helping leaders grow
yeah um so the idea of leadership worth
following
is that leaders should be worth
right um and and we we think of that in
terms of three broad buckets one is
uh you've got to have the capacity to
lead so can you help
people and teams and organizations get
where they need to go
you've got to have the commitment to
lead so are you willing to do the hard
work
and do the right things in order to make
it happen and then do you have the
character to lead
so will you be the kind of person that
people actually
want to follow and that they should be
following
right and so um developing yourself in
all three of those areas
is is critical but i do think that that
last one
character to lead is the one that most
people
uh it's getting more play these days but
i think that most people
aren't as aware of that or they're not
as intentional
in developing things like humility
gratitude uh openness transparency all
of those things
those are critical for being a high
character leader
and it's something that i think that
people aren't necessarily as intentional
uh in developing themselves on i think
people assume you either have it or you
don't but
but i think you can develop that
right and then and then how does it
actually tangibly work
you know you know how does what is the
actual interaction between the leaders
and
you know leadership with following or
whatever organization
they choose to work with yeah so our our
process we have a ton of different
processes but basically
um you know if you're if you're a
broader organization you come to us
um kind of looking to either hire or
promote or
develop leaders um and so we do
uh we do like role plays and simulations
to kind of uh assess people we do
personality testing
we do lots of like in-depth interviews
so it's a very high touch
process and environment um and then
the the kind of the other piece of uh
the puzzle is
is more just like coaching and so we use
assessments one of one of the
assessments is the drive
uh which is what i've kind of alluded to
and
a lot of i mean that's just a 20-minute
assessment so people pop online
take it and then we do some really high
high touch in-depth impactful uh
coaching to help
people develop the self-awareness and
it's not just about self-awareness but
it is about
the behavioral application as well so
specifically what are you going to do
differently and then a lot of times
we'll have like 360 assessments or
things like that
to give people a sense of are you making
the progress that you're intending to
make
you know i think one of the things that
i'm really getting out of here
and beyond a few things tangibly that i
want to be more thoughtful for myself
but
but it's more of the idea that
leadership is complex
and it's not a single sport and
especially today um it's something that
you know we i think that
there's also a bigger trend for for the
younger generation to grow into
leadership roles much quicker and which
with perhaps less
you know stability you know into inner
stability
and with less skills to go and really
have those debriefing moments and
introspection and
and what we started circling back this
thoughtfulness behind
the intentionality behind the actions
and why we do what we do and why we
choose to act the way we choose to act
and and so i'm taking i'm going to step
after this conversation and think for
myself a little bit so thank you for
that
uh but but i think this was just
wonderful and i really appreciate you
taking the time to be here
i have a few questions for chris not
about leadership
not about uh what you're doing are you
ready for them
yeah let's go for it so going back to
middle school and high school
what was one of your favorite classes um
so i feel like
i feel like it's this is a cop-out just
because uh i'm a psychologist but
psychology
was was one um and then
if i if i pick maybe a more surprising
one
um i was i actually really liked my ap
calculus class amazing
very very cool and who would be a role
model or somebody that inspires you
in some way shape or form um
so this one i i mean so i'm a christian
so i have to i have to go with
with jesus uh not i mean yes that's a
religious figure but i do think that
if you just look at the the the better
parts of the movement that he inspired
um you know jesus is an inspiration to
me so i've got to go with him
oh wonderful and the last question three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
um so i would say creative
um i would i and for better or for worse
i'm
i'm actually a pretty serious guy at
work at least
um try not to be like that in in real
life but that's how i end up uh at work
so creative serious i guess or focused
um and then i um
let's see um i would like
optimistic i think i like to be pretty
um optimistic and forgiving about people
um i try to you know if someone uh
does something wrong i try to give them
the benefit of the doubt
so i would say those three very very
cool chris
thank you so much for being here this
was wonderful and stay safe and stay
healthy continue helping leaders become
better leaders
at the end making you know making a more
positive impact on the world
and thank you for sharing with me and
you know your insights in your journey
thank you
i appreciate it thanks so much michael
thank you bye
[Music]
you